Vous pouvez remarquer comment on essaye à chaque fois de permettre que les textes bibliques guident et conduisent aussi nos prières pastorales.
Et ce que nous allons remarquer, ce que nous sommes en train de remarquer, c'est que les passages que nous avons devant nous
et les chapitres 4 des Philippiens d'une manière générale, dans lesquels on est en train de considérer les sources des joies chrétiennes pendant notre pèlerinage,
vous allez remarquer que tous les points que nous sommes en train de considérer ici,
ils sont d'une manière ou d'autre attachés à la réjouissance d'une joie qui est vécue au sein d'une communauté, au sein d'une église locale.
On est en train de considérer la joie tout simplement de la communion fraternelle, la joie de la prière communautaire,
la joie de la sanctification communautaire, la joie de la provision des ministres de l'évangile qui sont au travail pour implanter les églises,
qui sont chères aux églises locales, et la communauté ou la communion universelle.
Car vers la fin du chapitre 4, nous voyons comment Paul qui est à Rome salue ceux qui sont à Philippe
et qui en tant que représentant de plusieurs autres églises dit « tous les saints vous saluent ».
Et donc ici nous voyons vraiment une église très intéressée, ou des chrétiens très intéressés,
à l'établissement des églises en bonne santé, à la réjouissance des sources des joies au sein de ces églises,
et mobilisée pour l'implantation d'autres églises.
Comme quelqu'un a déjà dit par rapport au ministère de l'apôtre Paul,
il n'a jamais été intéressé dans ses efforts évangélistiques à former des pierres détachées d'un édifice,
des rolling stones, des pierres roulantes, car elles ne servent à rien.
Mais il était toujours intéressé à l'apôtre Paul que ces pierres vivantes soient en train de former
une représentation locale, une ambassade sur terre du royaume céleste.
Les églises tout simplement.
Donc c'est une aberration selon le Nouveau Testament des chrétiens sans église.
Et toutes les sources des joies qui nous sont présentées pour réjouir dans ces pèlerinages
sont accrochées à la vie d'une église locale ou à la vie de l'ensemble des églises locales universelles du Christ.
Et donc, c'est naturel, car l'église est le corps du Christ.
Et nous avons vu, et c'est la vérité générale, principale pour nous,
que les sommets et les fondements ultimes de la joie chrétienne
est le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
L'apôtre Paul au chapitre 3 des Philippiens,
il a dit que même s'il avait une vie très réussie,
lorsqu'il a connu véritablement le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
il a considéré tout comme de la boue
afin de gagner Christ.
C'était l'excellence de la connaissance de Jésus-Christ, son Seigneur,
qui a fait que toutes les étoiles de sa vie perdent leur bruit.
et comparablement à la joie qu'il a trouvée en Jésus-Christ,
tout est devenu complètement opaque, sans lumière.
Mais c'est intéressant, car l'apôtre Paul,
non seulement par cette connaissance du Seigneur Jésus-Christ qu'il a sauvée,
il a trouvé dans la vie et dans la beauté des vies du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
c'est-à-dire la manière dont il était en train de donner son tout,
sa vie même, pour promouvoir notre salut,
il a perçu qu'il pouvait connaître davantage le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
de manière expérimentale dans cette vie,
pour ce qui reste encore de notre pèlerinage,
à travers une vie conforme à Christ dans ses souffrances.
Donc ici l'apôtre Paul va exploser ce qu'on appelle la théologie de la prospérité,
car il retrouvait la joie de grandir en connaissance du Christ
par l'expérience de souffrir comme Christ pour les progrès de l'Évangile.
Par cette souffrance, il pourrait connaître de manière plus expérimentale
la douleur même que Christ a souffert pour nous à la croix,
mais plus que ça, c'était un Christ qui s'édonne
et donne même en s'exposant à la souffrance afin de faire promouvoir l'Évangile.
Et donc Paul va dire, en dévenant conforme à lui dans sa mort,
dans la communion de ses souffrances,
pour que je puisse par là connaître Christ et la puissance de sa résurrection.
Donc les souffrances sont un moyen de mieux connaître Christ,
d'être quelque part plus proche de Christ en termes de similarité,
mais aussi en termes de promesses.
Car Christ est particulièrement présent
lorsque nous sommes en train de souffrir pour les hommes de Dieu.
Et Christ est le fondement de cette joie aussi,
car il est une assurance inébranlable
qu'avec lui-même, Dieu nous donnera tout.
Donc la gloire future, on peut essayer de vendre chapitre 3,
notre cité à nous est dans les cieux,
d'où nous attendons aussi comme sauveurs et seigneurs,
les seigneurs Jésus-Christ, c'est-à-dire
les sommets de la joie chrétienne,
c'est non seulement les expériences anticipées avec les Christs ressuscités,
mais c'est la vision béatifique du Christ dans son retour.
L'encre de la joie chrétienne est d'attendre l'apparition glorieuse
de Saint-Jésus à son retour.
Mais il nous donnera avec lui une cité parfaite,
la restauration pleine de cet univers,
avec gloire, à nouveau,
habité dans des maisons glorieuses,
dans des pays qui n'ont plus besoin
des hôpitaux,
des prisons,
des tribunaux de justice,
n'est pas étant exposée aux catastrophes naturelles,
et donc notre cité à nous est dans les cieux.
Et en plus, c'est 21 qui transformera notre corps,
les corps d'humiliation,
l'humiliation de nos péchés,
l'humiliation des veillers, tout simplement,
d'être fragile, d'être exposé aux maladies.
Donc tout cela va finir.
Mais tout cela, à nouveau,
ce sont des choses dont nous avons l'encre de notre joie.
C'est une encre inébranlable,
mais c'est le fondement ultime de notre joie.
Tout cela en Christ, Christ au centre,
et tout cela déjà assuré.
Donc nous sommes déjà les plus riches de tout l'univers.
Et l'apôtre Paul, en ayant fixé nos encres
dans cette source inébranlable des joies
et constante des joies qu'il y a,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
à n'importe quelles circonstances des vies,
il nous propose les suivants.
Maintenant que vous avez Christ
comme sommet de votre joie et fondement ultime,
Christ toujours accessible,
peu importe les circonstances,
n'hésitez pas à réjouir
certaines sources des joies
que vous pouvez déjà réjouir.
Elles sont toutes trouvées,
comme je vous ai dit,
dans les contextes des Églises,
et c'est le mieux profit quelque part
de notre pèlerinage.
Car même si les choses semblent aller mal
dans plusieurs circonstances,
en ayant toujours ces choses à notre portée
pour saisir la joie qu'ils offrent,
nous devons être très intentionnels
à ne pas chercher à dévier notre attention
de ce que la Bible présente comme en étant
ce qui peut satisfaire la joie
de ceux qui sont vraiment nés de nouveau,
de ne pas nous livrer à l'attirance
des choses temporelles de ce monde,
mais de nous concentrer,
peu importe quelles soient nos circonstances,
à être sûrs que pendant tous les moments de nos vies,
nous sommes là en train de chercher
à puiser ces trésors des joies.
Ok ?
On a considéré quelques-uns,
donc le chapitre 4,
il est consacré à ça,
c'est l'application d'apôtre Paul,
en ayant Christ,
les seigneurs comme fondement ultime
de notre joie,
en Christ ou dans les seigneurs
pendant notre pèlerinage,
nous pouvons réjouir
de plusieurs sources des joies.
L'amour fraternel communautaire,
verset 1 à 5,
la prière communautaire,
verset 6 et 7,
par laquelle on réjouit
de la paix des dieux.
On a la sanctification communautaire,
verset 8 et 9,
une sanctification qui va s'emparer
de l'ensemble de l'être humain,
ça va garder les cœurs,
l'affection,
les résolutions,
la raison,
ça engage un repère
qu'il y a l'apôtre Paul lui-même
comme inspiration pour nos vies
et c'est cette résolution
à être sans
car la proportion
de la joie chrétienne,
elle est retrouvée
à la proportion
de la progression
en sanctification
car les purs des cœurs
verront Dieu.
Et donc si,
par les prières communautaires,
nous retrouvons
la paix des dieux,
l'apôtre Paul dit
qu'il y a par la résolution
à être sans,
nous retrouvons les dieux
de la paix,
Dieu lui-même.
Et ensuite,
la quatrième source
déjà présentée
sont les soins affectueux
envers les ministres
de l'Évangile,
versets 10 à 19,
ce que nous sommes en train
de considérer encore,
et vers la fin,
verset 20 à 23,
nous voyons la joie
de la communion universelle
entre tous les sangs.
Donc il y a la joie
au début
de la vie communautaire
dans une église locale
et il y a aussi
la joie
de la communion universelle
qui nous est présentée
au verset 20 à 23.
Donc nous sommes encore
en train de traiter
ces soins affectueux
envers les ministres
de l'Évangile.
Donc au verset 10,
nous revenons au verset 10 là,
et l'apôtre Paul,
il déclare ouvertement
que malgré le fait
d'être dans une prison,
il a pu expérimenter
une grande joie.
C'était une grande joie
toutefois encore
dans les seigneurs.
Ok ?
J'ai éprouvé
une grande joie
dans les seigneurs
de ceux qui vous avaient pu
enfin renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments pour moi.
Vous y pensez bien,
mais l'occasion vous manquait.
Donc,
lorsqu'on pense
à la joie
que nous pouvons retrouver
en tant qu'Église
par la provision
des soins affectueux
envers un ministre
de l'Évangile,
nous devons penser
dans un premier aspect,
c'est tout simplement
la joie
que cet homme,
ce ministre
est en train
d'expérimenter
car nous sommes en train
d'exprimer
par les dons
nos sentiments pour lui.
Donc Paul n'est pas fixé
sur les langages monétaires,
il est en train de dire
vous avez pu renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
envers moi.
Donc Paul,
il a expérimenté
cette joie
qui était perçue
par l'apôtre Paul
non seulement
comme l'expression
des sentiments
de cette Église,
mais l'expression
des sentiments
du Seigneur
et des sons du Seigneur
envers lui.
Cette Église,
dans la perspective
de ses ministres
qui étaient Paul,
était les bras
étendus
des dieux
pour porter
la provision
que Dieu lui-même
l'avait promis.
Donc il y a cette joie
de tout simplement
recevoir
l'amour soigneux
de l'Église
de la part des ministres.
Mais il y a aussi
de l'autre côté
la joie
de plaire
un ministre
bien aimé
et confirmer
des dieux.
Donc l'essence
des privilèges
de l'Église
des Philippes
de savoir
par cette parole
des Paul
qu'il a pu expérimenter
malgré sa souffrance,
il a pu expérimenter
la joie
qui a été produite
dans son cœur
par les dons
des Philippiens.
Donc Paul,
il était content,
attention,
non simplement du fait
qu'il a pu réjouir
de l'expression
de leurs sentiments,
mais remarquez bien,
vous avez pu enfin
renouveler
l'expression
de vos sentiments
envers moi.
Donc Paul était content
car ces personnes-là,
elles désiraient,
elles voulaient faire
ces dons,
elles n'arrivaient pas
comment faire,
mais là,
ils sont contents
d'avoir pu offert.
La joie
du contentement chrétien
est aussi un autre aspect
car l'apôtre Paul
va profiter
de cette situation
pour laisser
de manière très claire
que lui,
il n'était pas
intéressé
à ses besoins.
Cet éloge
n'était pas fondé
sur le fait
qu'il était en train
de grandir
en termes d'abondance
car la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
ne dépendait pas
de ce que les Philippiens
pourraient apporter
à sa vie.
Il dit
que ce n'est pas en vue,
c'est 11 de mes besoins
car j'ai appris
à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve.
C'est ça la définition
biblique.
Des vrais contentements,
des vraies joies,
une joie inébranlable,
c'est d'être content
de l'état
où nous nous trouvons.
C'est d'être sûr
que Dieu est notre Père Céleste,
il gouverne
tous les détails
de toutes les choses,
il nous aime,
il planifie
toutes les choses
pour nos biens,
il n'y a aucune chose
qui puisse résister
à ses soins envers nous.
Donc,
s'il a décidé
qu'aujourd'hui,
j'allais traverser
cette situation particulière
dans ma vie,
c'est pour mon bien.
J'ai appris à être content
de l'état
où je me trouve.
Par contre,
c'est une chose
d'entendre
ce que je viens de dire
de manière théorique
et même basée
sur les témoignages
d'autres personnes.
Mais Paul,
il est en train de dire
ici que ce qu'il est
en train de déclarer
est quelque chose
qui peut être confirmé
et attesté
dans sa vie
car il travaillera
pour que les rois
des dieux avancent
si les ressources
sont là ou non.
Mais Paul,
il est en train de dire
qu'il a appris
à être content
en toutes circonstances.
Donc c'est une école
expérimentale.
L'apôtre Paul,
il a dû traverser,
il dit ça,
j'ai appris
en tout
et partout,
j'ai appris
à être rassaisier,
à avoir fain,
être dans l'abondance
dans la 17,
à vivre dans l'humiliation
et dans l'abondance.
Donc l'apôtre Paul,
il comprenait
que selon les décisions
divines
de la Providence,
il pourrait traverser
des saisons
de privation
pour constater
que Christ,
était son tout
et tout suffisant
pour lui
et lorsqu'il était
dans l'abondance,
son amour pour Christ
pourrait davantage
se réjouir
car c'était
un sourire des dieux.
Il n'était pas
accroché au don,
il était accroché
au donateur.
Et donc,
il enseigne
aux Philippiens
par ses paroles
et par son témoignage
à embrasser
les moments particuliers
de la vie
où nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui
car tout cela
coopère à notre bien.
mais le centre
de ses contentements
en toutes circonstances
c'est le verset 13
qui nous dit
« Je puis tout
par celui
qui me fortifie »
car si une église
est en train
de pouvoir
à ses besoins,
il va reconnaître
que c'est
le Seigneur Jésus
à travers cette église
qui pourvoit
mes besoins.
Tout est connecté
à Christ.
Et lorsque les ressources
manquent,
le Seigneur Jésus
s'assure lui-même
des pouvoirs
de manière
surprenante,
directe,
miraculeuse.
Mais le Seigneur
n'a jamais manqué
à l'apôtre Paul.
Les délivrances
qu'il a vécues,
la préservation
de sa vie,
les provisions divines,
que ce soit
à travers les églises
responsables,
mature,
que ce soit
par Christ lui-même.
Et même lorsque
les ressources
manquent complètement
apparemment,
la présence
du Christ suffit.
Paul a été
visité en prison
par le Seigneur Jésus
lui-même
pour les fortifier.
Lorsqu'ils tous
l'avaient abandonné
et qu'ils devraient
porter un témoignage,
il a fait avec
intégrité,
avec fermeté,
car le Seigneur Jésus
l'a fortifié
pour les faire.
C'est quelque chose
que nous n'allons
qu'égrandir
dans cette école
si nous embrassons,
comme disait Spurgeon,
j'ai appris
à embrasser
les vagues
qui me lancent
contre les rochers
des âges.
Il vaut mieux laisser
que cette vague
de souffrance
m'écrase
dans les rochers
des âges
qu'il a écrit
sur lui-même
car lui,
il va prendre
soin de moi
et va produire
mon mieux.
La maturité
de cette église
est évidente
et elle était aussi,
attention,
une source
des joies
liée
à la provision
affectueuse
d'un ministre
car cette église
a démontré
une profonde
maturité
missionnaire
car si
dans les versets 13
l'apôtre Paul
dit
j'ai pu tout
parce qu'elle
qui me fortifie,
dans les versets 14
il dit
vous avez bien fait
de prendre part
à ma détresse.
C'est-à-dire
d'un côté
Paul aurait pu
devenir un arrogant
très mystique
en disant
Christ me suffit
je pars partout
si vous ne voulez pas
offrir aucune chose
l'évangile va progresser
et le Seigneur va pouvoir.
Je n'ai besoin
d'aucune aide
d'aucune ressource
il pourrait devenir
heureux pour dire
je préfère partir
sans rien recevoir
comme il a dû faire
dans cette incirconstance
à cause
du manque
de maturité
les Corinthiens
par exemple
ou en acte
vent
les personnes
qui mal intentionnées
avec un cœur
déplacé
auraient pu dire
l'apôtre Paul
n'est qu'il
dans cette position
à ce moment
à cause des mes dons
des mes contributions
des non-contributions
mais ce n'était pas
la disposition
des cœurs
des Philippiens
ils n'étaient pas
préoccupés
avec les crédits
qui auraient pu
abonder
pour leur compte
et l'apôtre Paul
il va préciser
ça ici
leur intérêt
c'était tout simplement
de plaire Dieu
d'honorer
l'homme des dieux
de faire avancer
les rames des dieux
vous comprenez
et donc
il y a une maturité
missionnaire
incroyable
dans ces passages
qui est démontrée
et éprouvée
par plusieurs aspects
la maturité théologique
car c'est une église
qui comprenait
l'équilibre
entre
un Christ
qui a promis
qu'il va pouvoir
toujours
aux besoins de ses sangs
souveraineté des dieux
et de l'autre côté
vous avez fait
quelque chose
d'excellent
de prendre part
à ma détresse
c'est-à-dire
une église
qui savait
que Dieu
va prendre soin
des Paul
mais Dieu
va prendre soin
des Paul
aussi à travers
notre responsabilité
en tant qu'église
donc une église
théologiquement équilibrée
en termes de mission
une église aussi
en termes de maturité
dans sa compassion
elle a pris part
à la détresse
d'Epaul
elle est entrée
dans la prison
d'Epaul
c'est un rappel
de ce que le Seigneur Jésus
Christ lui-même a dit
si vous avez visité
un seul de ces petits
vous m'avez visité
à moi-même
en prison
et donc
c'est une église
qui sait
si un homme
des dieux fidèles
est en train
de périr
injustement
sous persécution
dans une prison
c'est notre responsabilité
solidaire
d'y aller
et souffrir
avec lui
on participe
au progrès
de l'Evangile
à travers leur service
on participe aussi
à ces souffrances
elle était aussi mature
en termes
de justice
car l'apôtre Paul
utilise un langage
d'affaires
ici
verset 15
lorsqu'il dit
vous les savez vous-même
au commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
lorsque j'ai parti
de la Macédoine
aucune église
n'entra en compte
avec moi
pour ce qu'elle donnait
et recevait
c'est-à-dire
nous recevons
quelque chose
de la part
des serviteurs
du Christ
et nous devons
contrer
ce que nous recevons
avec un salaire
ou une rémunération
digne
si possible
proportionnelle
à ce qu'on reçoit
et c'est clair ici
que les principes
de justice
il est tout simplement
clairement assimilé
tout comme
le Saint Jésus
a enseigné
les travailleurs
méritent
son salaire
c'était aussi
une maturité
visionnaire
dans tes prises
pour les missions
car
au commencement
de la prédication
de l'évangile
aucune église
n'entra en compte
avec moi
et au verset 16
il dit
vous fûtes
les seuls
à les faire
donc c'est une église
qui a été suffisamment
mature pour dire
on n'a pas beaucoup
d'évidence
des fruits
ou des signes
des croissances
on n'est pas à l'attente
de voir les résultats
pour aider
on a identifié
un ministre fidèle
une nécessité
pour l'avancement
de l'évangile
une région
qui a besoin
de l'évangile
nous allons
sponsoriser
cette mission
nous allons
investir
dans les règles
des dieux
et donc
ils étaient les seuls
ils sont devenus
un repère
ils ont eu
la responsabilité
d'être un repère
on voit aussi
la maturité
en termes
de régularité
verset 16
car vous m'envoyez
déjà
à Thessalonique
et à deux reprises
des quoi pourvoir
à mes besoins
et particulièrement ici
il est en train
à nouveau
de remercier
ce qu'il vient
de recevoir
de la part
des Philippiens
régularité
il y a aussi
la conscience
la maturité
d'être conscient
de participer
à l'oeuvre missionnaire
de l'apôtre Paul
c'est pas que je cherche
vos dons
ou les dons
mais je cherche
les fruits
qui abondent
pour votre compte
tous les fruits
des premières églises
qui ont été implantées
en Europe
qui ont eu
ces petits commencements
ici
tous les fruits
ont été crédités
bien sûr
dans les comptes
des services
de l'apôtre Paul
ultimement
bien sûr
la grâce
de Dieu
toujours
mais Dieu
comme Dieu
fait usage
des moyens secondaires
des efforts
des Paul
des contributions
des Philippiens
Dieu est en train
de noter
et par sa grâce
il va récompenser
proportionnellement
avec abondance
et donc là
on va de manière
très intéressante
la maturité
de cette participation
missionnaire
ils savaient
que les plus
ils investissaient
envers un homme
des dieux
à cause de la maturité
et l'intégrité
de cet homme des dieux
les plus seraient
investis
proportionnellement
ils seraient
motivés proportionnellement
pour s'investir
dans l'évangile
dans la promotion
de l'évangile
et par la grâce
des dieux
les plus on s'investit
pour faire avancer
l'enroi
par nos efforts
par les partages
de l'évangile
les plus on est en train
de lancer des séments
les plus des probabilités
dans l'ordre naturel
des choses
nous allons avoir
dévoi les progrès
de l'évangile
une église
qui fait terre
devant sa génération
pour plus qu'elle prie
elle ne peut pas
s'attendre
dévoire beaucoup de fruits
il faut prier
et travailler
il faut travailler
et prier
elle était mature
en termes de générosité
missionnaire
car j'ai tout reçu
je suis dans l'abondance
j'ai été comblé
des biens
en recevant
des paprodites
ce qui vient de vous
et la dernière chose
qu'on a vu
c'était la maturité
de la prestation
des comptes
la supervision
Hendrickson
il va observer
que lorsque l'apôtre Paul
dit
j'ai tout reçu
dans ce contexte
où il est en train
d'utiliser un langage
d'affaires
de rémunération
c'est comme s'il était
en train de
d'écrire officiellement
une espèce de reçu
cette lettre
envoyée aux philippiens
qui comprenait
ces paragraphes
et ce que Paul
voulait faire
c'était d'attester
l'intégrité
de cet homme
qui a été envoyé
pour apporter ses biens
il n'y a pas eu
des déviations
des biens
à cet égard
c'est intéressant
à remarquer
l'apôtre Paul
ici
démontre une sagesse
une maturité aussi
car lui
de sa part
il est aussi
en train de démontrer
une espèce
de soumission
comme il a fait
envers Antioche
il est l'autorité
suprême
en termes d'office
d'église
il est apôtre
et en même temps
il va rendre compte
à Antioche
ici il est en train
de rendre compte
à Philippe
à l'église des philippiens
il est en train
de dire
j'ai tout reçu
ok
c'est comme si
il l'avait reçu
en paiement
et voilà
comme s'il était
en train de donner
un reçu
mais comme c'était
une lettre
lue
à une communauté
il n'y a pas
mention
ici
de la valeur
en soi
donc ça
ça nous donne
une marge
de sagesse
car à chaque fois
qu'on voit
dans la Bible
donc c'est une lettre
adressée
attention
si on revient
à chapitre 1
aux anciens
à toute l'église
mais à travers
la médiation
des anciens
et les diacres
donc
les plus
probablement
les anciens
et les diacres
étaient conscients
de quoi s'agissaient
du montant
etc
mais ici
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
cette église
elle était supervisée
par les anciens
et les diacres
et Paphrodite
était un homme
intègre
rédévable
et voilà pourquoi
on a ici
des bases bibliques
pour considérer
que l'intégrité
soit sécurisée
des deux parties
et cela donne
de la liberté
car
Paul
il utilise
surtout
les langages
d'expression
des sentiments
des soins
d'amour
d'avancement
du royaume
mais comme il faut
traiter
de ce que Christ
lui-même appelait
les mamans
d'iniquité
qui a toujours
ces côtés obscurs
qui cherchent toujours
à s'emparer
de nos cœurs
il y a certaines mesures
qui
protègent
cette liberté
au lieu
qu'il soit toujours
en train de chercher
à défendre
pour prouver
son intégrité
il peut
recevoir
et réjouir
de cette abondance
qu'il est pourvue
ponctuellement
à ces moments
car il sait
que cette église
a été responsable
pour évaluer
son appel
pour superviser
la manière
dont il va gérer
ces choses
et toute la communauté
s'est réjouie
aussi
d'avoir
la confirmation
d'un représentant
intègre
et pas fraudite
qui a confirmé
il y a plusieurs mesures
qu'on prend
par exemple
dans l'organisation
de l'église
dans la trésorerie
par exemple
il faut toujours avoir
deux personnes
qui travaillent
pour compter
par exemple
les dons
il faut toujours avoir
deux personnes là
pour être très sûr
que nous sommes toujours
dans la transparence
et dans la prestation
des comptes
et donc la maturité
se montre
même là
dans l'organisation
d'une église
je sais que tout cela
peut sembler
un peu trop technique
mais c'est ça
qui nous protège
notamment
des diffamations
c'est ça qui nous protège
d'être confondus
par exemple
avec ceux
de la théologie
de la prospérité
mais nous devons avancer
car
il y a encore
un autre aspect
de cette joie
quand on prend soin
des ministres
et c'est la plus sublime
c'est celle
que nous allons retrouver
dans les versets 18
lorsque l'apôtre Paul
il dit
dans la deuxième partie
du verset 18
j'ai tout reçu
et je suis dans l'abondance
j'ai été comblé
des biens
en recevant
par Epaphrodite
ce qui vient de vous
comme quoi
comme un parfum
des bonnes odeurs
un sacrifice
que Dieu accepte
et qui lui est
agréable
donc attention
à ce que l'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire
une église
ne devrait pas
hésiter
à honorer
à pourvoir
à offrir
des dons
pour les soins
du ministre
afin qu'il puisse
continuer l'oeuvre
des dieux
car
en les faisant
elle est en train
de partager
du plaisir
des dieux lui-même
sur les soins
affectueux
que Dieu lui-même
veut apporter
à ses fidèles
à ses ministres
Jésus-Christ
lui-même
il a dit
tout ce qui
ont tout laissé
pour me servir
j'assure
qu'ils recevront
sans fin
encore dans cette vie
avec persécution
avec des saisons
des grandes difficultés
et la gloire
à venir
et la vie éternelle
dans les mondes
à venir
et donc ici
nous devons comprendre
qui les offrandent
envers les envoyés
du Christ
sont reçus
directement
comme si
offertes
à celui
qui les a envoyés
c'est comme si
le seigneur Jésus
lui-même
qui est représenté
par un ministre fidèle
était en train
de recevoir
lui-même
ce qu'on est en train
de donner
à ses représentants
trois choses
intéressantes
à percevoir ici
les offrandes
aux ministres
sont
des offrandes
agréables
à Dieu
les offrandes
sont donc
une forme
d'adoration
des fois
on entend
des témoignages
et je peux comprendre
c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment
pour
c'est vraiment pas
porter
un sévère jugement
je pense
que c'est
les résultats
d'avoir été exposé
à une génération
qui a trop abusé
des fausses églises
des faux prophètes
un tabu aussi
dans la génération
de parler de l'argent
tout simplement
il y a plusieurs églises
aujourd'hui
qui
préfèrent
de ne pas
insérer
dans l'ordre
de leur culte
les moments
d'offrandes
déjà on a
dans l'histoire
de l'église
la confirmation
qui ça a toujours
fait partie
on voit
dans les nouveaux
testaments
que cette pratique
est préservée
non seulement
par la pratique
ou les principes
en soi
mais aussi
car
bibliquement
les offrandes
sont
une manière
d'adorer
et notre culte
public
c'est un culte
d'adoration
et donc
nous pouvons
parfois
nous abstenir
d'une responsabilité
qui est un autre
et qui parfois
est difficile
de toucher
à ces sujets
sous peine
d'être
jugé
par les mauvaises
interférences
du moment
d'iniquité
des personnes
qui peuvent
douter
de nos intentions
pourquoi on est
en train de parler
sur certains sujets
et la réalité
c'est que l'apôtre Paul ici
il vise
à amener
non seulement
Philippe
ou l'église
de Philippe
à la maturité
mais toutes les églises
qui auront
et saisiront
cette lettre
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
c'est qu'il vient
de vous
comme un parfum
des bonnes odeurs
un sacrifice
qui est Dieu accepte
et qui lui est
agréable
donc Paul il est ici
en train
de comparer
les dons envoyés
aux ministres
fidèles
et surtout
lorsqu'on considère
certaines circonstances
particulières
comme l'emprisonnement
des Paul
sous persécution
mais il considère
que les dons
aux ministres
du Christ
sont comparables
aux offrandes
les plus agréables
à Dieu
ces trois expressions
sont tirées
de la pratique
de l'Ancien Testament
de l'adoration
donc Paul
il est en train
de participer
à la joie
des dieux
car il reçoit
avec la joie
d'un ministre
fidèle
qui est en train
de contempler
une église mature
Paul va mourir
bientôt
il partira
mais sa joie
c'est de savoir
que cette église
est arrivée
en maturité
où
les prochains ministres
qui seront là
disposés
à consacrer
leur vie
et risquer
tout leur confort
et leur santé
leur sécurité
auront
et pourront
compter
par l'exemple
de cette église
et par les ressources
avec cette même provision
donc Paul
il est en train
de recevoir
ses biens
en identifiant
non
sur ses biens
mais à travers
ses biens
la maturité
de cette église
qui plaît
le cœur
de Dieu
donc l'apôtre Paul
il est en train
de se réjouir
de voir une église
généreuse
et Paphrodite
et les Philippiens
certainement
sont en train
de trouver ici
les loges
les plus sublimes
qu'ils pourraient
recevoir
à la part d'Épaule
car pour plus
que des fois
on soit tenté
à trop chérir
l'homme
en qui l'œuvre
des dieux habite
c'est clair
que les Philippiens
les étaient
beaucoup plus intéressés
à plaire Dieu
qu'Épaule
et lorsqu'ils écoutent
la part d'Épaule
ce qui vient de vous
est reçu par Dieu
comme un parfum agréable
vos prières
pour les missions
c'est un parfum agréable
mais vos sacrifices
les dons
ils les sont aussi
et peut-être plus
car ils sont aussi
accompagnés
par vos prières
et Dieu
s'est réjoui
des offrandes
des Philippiens
c'est clair
en recevant
par Épaphrodite
ce qui vient de vous
comme un parfum
des bonnes odeurs
un sacrifice
que Dieu accepte
ce que nous devons saisir
par cet exemple
c'est que Dieu
reçoit
comme pour lui-même
les bienfaits
envers ses représentants
en Matthieu 10
verset 40
le Seigneur Jésus
dit
celui qui vous reçoit
m'éreçoit
et celui qui m'éreçoit
reçoit
celui qui m'a envoyé
celui qui reçoit
un prophète
en qualité des prophètes
recevra une récompense
des prophètes
et celui qui reçoit
un juste
en qualité des justes
recevra une récompense
des justes
et quiconque donnera
seulement un verre d'eau froide
à l'un de ses petits
parce qu'il est mon disciple
je vous l'ai dit en vérité
il ne perdra point
sa récompense
Matthieu 20 verset 40
et le roi
leur répondra
je vous l'ai dit
en vérité
toutes les fois
que vous avez fait
ces choses
à l'un de ses plus petits
de mes frères
c'est à moi
que vous l'avez fait
et donc
bien sûr
il faut qu'on soit
en train d'évaluer
la légitimité
l'intégrité
de quelqu'un
qui est véritablement
appelé au ministère
et de quelqu'un
qui est responsable
dans l'exercice
du ministère
mais si nous sommes
devant un vrai représentant
nous devons savoir
que les dons
offerts au ministre
de l'évangile
sont pris par Christ
comme si c'était
reçu par lui-même
et le deuxième aspect
c'est que ces dons
offerts
au ministre
sont comparables
aux offrandes
les plus agréables à Dieu
il y a trois critères
pour qu'une offrande
soit acceptable
si nous sommes
véritablement
des chrétiens
et malheureusement
même pour ceux
qui ne sont pas chrétiens
des fois
ils essayent de faire
quelque chose
pour plaire Dieu
j'ai déjà raconté
cette histoire ici
mais ça m'a touché
ces témoignages
où un pasteur
d'une église simple
un jour
un homme
les maris
d'une croyante
une femme de l'église
qui n'était pas chrétien
lui
qui venait très rarement
il est venu apporter
un chèque à l'église
et c'était un somme
assez important
si nous ne connaissons pas
une personne
et qu'une personne
fait un don
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
un problème avec ça
mais lui
il était au courant
de ce qui se passait
dans la vie de cette famille
et donc au lieu
de prendre
cet argent
et déposer
dans les comptes
de l'église
il est venu
appeler cet homme
à la fin du culte
il a rendu
l'échec à nouveau
car il était conscient
que c'était une personne
qui était agressive
violente
envers sa femme
et il lui a dit
Dieu n'est pas
intéressé
à ton argent
Dieu est intéressé
à ton cœur
dans l'Ancien Testament
nous avons
plein
des références bibliques
où
l'adoration
et les offrandes
sont hypocrites
vous m'éloyez
avec vos lèvres
mais vos cœurs
sont loin des mois
nos prières
sont toujours
nos offrandes
nos bonnes œuvres
et même
l'entrévue
elle est toujours
imparfaite
elle doit toujours
être accompagnée
des prières
notamment
et cette fommée
de ces parfums
qui m'ont agréable
des holocaustes
qui représentent
les Christs
c'est lui
qui purifie
nos dons
nos offrandes
nos expressions
d'adoration
pour qu'il soit
acceptable à Dieu
mais ce qui détermine
l'authenticité
d'une offrande
agréable à Dieu
sont trois aspects
le premier
c'est la prescription
biblique
il faut faire les dons
comme la parole
nous le dit
et ici c'est intéressant
car les dons
aux ministres
sont confirmés
davantage
comme une ordonnance
du Nouveau Testament
ça fait partie
des commandements
bibliques
du Nouveau Testament
qu'ils soient
implicites
ou explicites
la contribution
régulière
les principes
des primices
la priorité
pour les roms
des dieux
c'est comme ça
que la fin
nous est arrivée
jusqu'aujourd'hui
par les contributions
des philippiens
par exemple
et dans les cadres
des responsabilités
d'une église
la Bible
elle est claire aussi
par rapport
à comment nous devons
gérer
ce qui rentre
dans les comptes
de l'église
c'est courir
ceux qui traversent
des situations
difficiles
financières
dans la communauté
investir
en mission
aider les pauvres
de manière générale
mais l'une des priorités
primaires
c'est de soutenir
ceux qui vont consacrer
leur vie
à temps plein
pour les ministères
donc ici
c'est la confirmation
de l'apôtre Paul
lui-même
qui l'est fait aussi
par plusieurs
d'autres textes
qu'une église
doit considérer
comme une forme
d'adoration
cette prescription
des souvenirs
aux besoins
d'un homme des dieux
c'est intéressant
il y a aussi
la disposition
du coeur
donc les philippiens
clairement
ils étaient en train
de prendre
de la joie
ils étaient en train
de faire quelque chose
volontairement
et ici
ils sont comparables
à ces offrandes
volontaires
ou les termes
sacrifice
qui apportent
la notion
même si
à nouveau
la Bible
nous donne
plusieurs circonstances
avec plusieurs
répères différents
selon les circonstances
de nos contributions
c'est clair
que nos contributions
régulières
peuvent compter
d'une espèce
d'administration
sage et pieuse
où nous allons
toujours séparer
les prémices
en montant défini
pour donner
à ce qui est prioritaire
pour les hommes
de Dieu
tout le reste
rédivable à Dieu
de manière créative
de comment on va gérer
l'argent de Dieu
sous notre entendance
mais toujours
rédivable
envers la piété
on a toute la liberté
d'utiliser
notre argent
de donner
les prémices
quelque part
à l'église locale
mais à partir
de là
soutenir
un missionnaire
aider
une famille
qui traverse
une situation
difficile
pratiquer
l'hospitalité
pour inviter
les voisins
pour partager
l'évangile
faire un voyage
avec la famille
pour nous reposer
un peu
car on a besoin
de nous restaurer
d'avoir
une tente qualité
d'intensifier
la dévotion familiale
de restructurer
les choses
tout cela passe
par la progression
en piété
et nous sommes libres
et rédivables
de notre jeu
de comment on va gérer
nos finances
mais ce qui est
très intéressant
à remarquer ici
c'est qu'il y a
certaines priorités
qui doivent être régulières
et il y a
la conception
des sacrifices
aussi
qui mettait
toujours
l'emphase
sur l'aspect
couteau
des dons
sacrificiels
et cela
peut devenir
circonstanciel
donc si Paul
est en prison
on va laisser
de côté
certains privilèges
de nos familles
au sein de cette église
pour venir
à l'aide
de cet homme
vous comprenez ?
à plusieurs reprises
la Bible dit
c'est de votre superflu
que vous devez
offrir à Dieu
et en même temps
il va chérir
l'offrande
de cette pauvre veuve
qui va donner son tout
donc c'est
l'ensemble
de ce que nous avons
nous allons gérer
pour la gloire de Dieu
dans la liberté
et rédivabilité
que nous avons tous
par contre
il y a
quelques paramètres
et quelques critères
et devant
certaines circonstances
je peux
attendre de nous
qu'il nous fassion
en sacrifice
une autre
qui soit
davantage agréable
à Dieu
à cause des circonstances
vous comprenez ?
c'est clair ?
voici ce qu'il dit
Jean Calvin
à l'égard
de la beauté
de ce qu'il dit
ici
il dit
hélas pour notre paresse
c'est là
c'est manifeste
on sait que
bien que Dieu
nous invite
avec tant de bonté
à l'honneur
du sacerdoce
et qu'il mette
même entre nos morts
les sacrifices
à lui offrir
nous ne les
lui présentons
pourtant point
et ces choses
qui avaient été
mises à part
pour les sang
ablation
non seulement
nous les détournons
vers les osages
profondes
mais nous les gaspillons
méchantement
dans les soignures
les plus impures
et fois
Dieu est en train
d'être
des pouvoirs
avec
ample
suffisance
à nos besoins
afin qu'il nous
puisse surabonder
pour toutes
les bonnes œuvres
Dieu
enrichit
certains d'entre nous
pour que nous
soyons davantage
énervant vers
les missions
tout simplement
mais Dieu
a envoyé
en nous disant
comme Job
a pu dire
que la provision
de la veuve
et de l'orphelin
venait sur lui
mais plusieurs
au lieu
de rediriger
vers ceux
qui ont besoin
gardent
pour eux-mêmes
et certains
sont en train
de prier
Seigneur
tu m'avais promis
que je ne serais pas
en train de traverser
cette raison
et Dieu
est en train
de répondre
oui
j'ai été donné
la provision
mais j'ai été donné
par l'avis
de ton frère
mais il a pensé
que c'était pour lui
et il a tout gardé
pour lui
il continue
il dit
car les hôtels
sur lesquels
les sacrifices
de nos biens
devraient être offerts
ce sont les pauvres
et les serviteurs
de Christ
en négligeant cela
les uns gaspillent
leurs ressources
dans toutes sortes
de luxe
les autres
les engloutissent
par les ventres
et d'autres encore
les dissipent
en vêtements immodestes
ou en demeure
somptueuses
de quelle manière
sommes-nous en train
de profiter
des ressources
des dieux
qui sont mises
dans nos mains
afin d'honorer
!
les sacerdoces
donc Dieu
prend plaisir
les philippiens
prennent plaisir
l'apôtre
prend plaisir
tous
se réjouissent
de la générosité
d'une église
mais au verset 19
nous voyons
une motivation
légitime
qui est rajoutée ici
qui représente
tout simplement
l'une des plus grandes
promesses des écritures
la joie
de l'assurance
de la provision divine
lorsque nous
nous occupons
des affaires
des dieux
Dieu
s'occupe
de nos affaires
je sais que
plusieurs ont utilisé
ce que je veux dire
de manière
très tordue
ce de la théologie
de la prospérité
mais Dieu
lui-même
nous encourage
à les mettre
à l'épreuve
si nous avons
par la générosité
pas un intérêt
à recevoir
de la part
de Dieu
comme rémunération
l'argent
car là c'est
l'idolâtrie
de l'argent
mais si nous faisons
librement
nous sommes en train
de montrer à Dieu
où est notre cœur
c'est comme Salomon
qu'au début
de son ministère
il a dit à Dieu
je te demande
de la sagesse
pour prendre soin
de ton peuple
il n'a pas demandé
de l'argent
de la puissance
et Dieu a dit
comme tu n'as pas demandé
de l'argent
mais
quand
pour prendre soin
de mon peuple
avec la sagesse
je te comblerai
pourquoi certains
d'entre nous
prospèrent
et d'autres pas
donc il y a des raisons
infinies
mais l'une des raisons
c'est tout simplement
car on aurait pu
tomber vite
dans l'idolâtrie
mais c'est intéressant
verset 19
et mon Dieu
pourvoira
tout rebesoin
selon sa richesse
avec gloire
en Jésus Christ
un autre Dieu
et perçoit la gloire
au siècle des siècles
à mai
qu'est-ce que nous voyons ici
nous sommes devant
la pleine assurance
qui peut réjouir
de la pleine assurance
que Dieu
pourrait même
ne pas
décider
dans les prochains mois
ou dans les prochaines années
nous préserver
dans l'école
du contentement
par la privation
la réponse ici
c'est que les philippiens
pourraient être sûrs
que rien ne leur manquerait
car ils étaient en train
de suivre les sermons
de Jésus en Matthieu 6
chercher d'abord
les rois
de Dieu
et sa justice
et toutes ces autres choses
vous seront rajoutées
par-dessus
si Dieu n'a pas
épargné son propre fils
comment
ne nous donnera-t-il pas
avec lui
toutes les choses
donc la question
c'est ici
nous sommes devant
un sacrifice
d'adoration
très généreux
qui manifestait
un cœur
au bon endroit
et la réponse
soyez sûrs
que Dieu
ne va vous manquer
jamais
votre cœur
est au bon endroit
et c'est 19
et mon Dieu
donc déjà
nous sommes devant
un constat apostolique
mon Dieu
bientôt notre Dieu
mais pour l'instant
mon Dieu
quel est l'intérêt
de considérer
les mon Dieu
de l'apôtre Paul
donc nous sommes
une église
d'apprentices
philippiens
devant un homme
qui est un apôtre
confirmé
devant un homme
dont la théologie
est parfaite
donc lorsque
l'apôtre Paul
il dit
mon Dieu
ce que nous devons
comprendre par là
d'abord c'est
quelqu'un
qui connaît
parfaitement
Dieu
de manière
théologique
protégé par le
Saint-Esprit
pour interpréter
l'Ancien Testament
et pour rédiger
les nouveaux
mon Dieu
si lui
peut dire
quelque chose
à propos
de Dieu
nous pouvons être
sûrs que c'est vrai
nous ne pouvons pas
douter
il est capable
de présenter
l'évangile
avec perfection
précision
clarté
et il est en train
de faire une connexion
infiniment
réconfortante ici
car vous êtes en train
de contribuer
généreusement
à l'avancement
de l'homme
des dieux
en honorant
un ministre fidèle
vous pouvez être
sûrs
que ces dieux
là
sont justes
ces dieux là
sont généreux
ne vont pas
vous manquer
donc nous sommes
devant un constat
apostolique
théologiquement parfait
d'accord
on n'a pas
les droits
de douter
vous comprenez
ce que je suis en train
de dire
c'est Bible
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
mon Dieu
est profondément
expérimental
c'est ce que
l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de dire ici
c'est ce qu'il
nous devrions
tous dire
pouvoir
les dire
mon Dieu
vous êtes en train
de prier
chez vous
est-ce que vous êtes
en train de prier
un dieu
longtemps
distant
est-ce que c'est
les dieux
de vos parents
du pasteur
vous pouvez dire
mon dieu
et l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de parler
de son dieu
de manière profondément
expérimentale
il est en train
de parler
de son dieu
les mêmes dieux
qui a raccompagné
Paul
dans l'école
de la souffrance
du contentement
vous êtes avec moi
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est tout ce que vous êtes
en train d'accompagner
à propos de ma vie
les manières
miraculeuses
les délivrances
les préservations
la manière
dont Christ lui-même
est venu me visiter
dans les moments
les plus difficiles
c'est Dieu
que je peux dire
que c'est les miens
je peux m'approprier
de ces dieux
lorsque je lis la Bible
je sais qu'il y a
des vérités
qui concernent
tous les peuples de Dieu
tous les chrétiens
de manière générale
mais lorsque je lis la Bible
je peux comprendre
que c'est pour moi
c'est mon dieu
c'est ma relation
avec Dieu
Philippien
j'étais devant des églises
qui ne sont pas
suffisamment mûres
et qui n'ont rien prévu
mais mon dieu
a toujours prévu
à tous mes besoins
Philippien
vous êtes très matures
c'est incroyable
de voir votre maturité
votre générosité
sachez que mon dieu
sera avec vous
c'est un mon dieu
que nous devons
tous avoir
c'est un mon dieu
que nous allons
tous constater
le plus on se conforme
à une vie missionnaire
comme celle de l'apôtre Paul
qui est un modèle pour tous
comme les pasteurs
est un modèle pour tous
le plus vous vous engagez
dans les défis
que vous devez avoir
et même les réunions
de certaines promotions
parfois
pour rester intègre
dans votre travail
pour faire promouvoir
l'évangile
pour prendre des risques
pour proclamer la vérité
mon dieu
sera toujours là
en train de pourvoir
mon dieu
c'est les dieux
de l'apôtre Paul
qui les connaît
personnellement
théologiquement
il pourvoira
à tous vos besoins
tous vos besoins
en Jésus Christ
il y a plein
des désirs
qu'on a
qui sont idolâtres
nous avons les ouverts
de partager à Dieu
car il est notre père
il connaît mieux que nous
mais nous devons avoir
les réponses
en Dieu
sachant
il va me donner
quelques choses
qui vont faire du bien
pour moi
et mon dieu
pourvoira
à tous vos besoins
donc pas forcément
tous mes désirs
mais tous mes besoins
et particulièrement
tous mes besoins
en Christ Jésus
tous ces dont j'ai besoin
pour réjouir
de la présence de Jésus
pour me conformer
plus à Christ
pour développer
ma piété
tous ces dont j'ai besoin
surtout
pour faire promouvoir
son royaume
sauf que
selon la nature
de la générosité
de Dieu
c'est
tous nos besoins
selon sa richesse
si
nous ne sommes pas
contemplés
aujourd'hui
par l'abondance
de ce monde
nous pouvons être
sûrs d'une chose
ce n'est pas
par manque
d'amour
de Dieu
pour nous
ce n'est pas
par manque
de puissance
de Dieu
ce n'est pas
par manque
de bonnes intentions
de Dieu
envers nous
et c'est encore
moins par manque
de ressources
car tout
appartient
à Dieu
et s'il a décidé
que j'allais traverser
ce que je traverse
aujourd'hui
c'est soit
car il est en train
de me préparer
davantage
pour participer
à sa nature
pour avoir plus
d'intimité
avec lui
pour des manières
surprenantes
faire que son royaume
avance à travers
ma vie
de manière
surprenante
que je ne connais pas
soit il est en train
de corriger
certaines choses
dans mon coeur
qui doivent être
corrigées
purifiées
mais il pourvoit
toujours
selon sa richesse
il est généreux
ce n'est pas un Dieu
qui est intéressé
à pourvoir toujours
les minimums
suffisants
pour la subsistance
c'est les dieux
qui est propriétaire
de toutes les choses
des fois on a envie
de dire certaines choses
qui peuvent être comprises
de manière complexe
Dieu ne manque pas
de ressources
donc nous ne devrions pas
être si préoccupés
car un jour
la question a été posée
à pouraché par exemple
il y a certains
missionnaires en Europe
qui peuvent vouloir
100 missionnaires au Pérou
ou dans des lieux
très peuvres
en Afrique
mais Dieu n'est pas
en train de quantifier
la valeur des âmes
ou quantifier
la quantité d'églises
dont on a besoin
pour sauver
une seule âme
les coûts pour Dieu
c'était de donner
son tout
son fils
il n'y a pas
des ressources
qui manquent
en Dieu
et si nous j'en
que c'est nécessaire
par exemple
parfois d'avoir
un travail missionnaire
dans un lieu très cher
il faut voir
les âmes ont besoin
de l'évangile
peu importe
où elles sont
nous devons être préoccupés
à faire une chose
sans négliger l'autre
nous devons être préoccupés
à tout simplement
être généreux
pour investir
dans les royaumes
et ne pas raisonner
avec la mentalité
du minimum
suffisant
pour la subsistance
c'est un principe
paternel des dieux
et même
dans nos familles
on doit représenter
la générosité des dieux
et faire certains sacrifices
envers nos familles
envers nos épouses
nos enfants
et savoir filtrer
toutes les critiques
légitimes
qu'on puisse faire
à un capitalisme
exagéré d'un côté
ou à un communisme
ou socialisme
exagéré de l'autre côté
et de savoir
que Dieu nous appelle
à avoir contentement
dans la simplicité
à être équitable
dans la distribution
et ne pas négliger
le fait
que Dieu est le propriétaire
de toutes les choses
et il nous donne
des bonnes choses
de manière généreuse
pour qu'on réjouisse
donc il faut faire attention
avec l'austérité
avec laquelle
on essaye d'élever
nos enfants
qui peut supprimer
la joie
et les plaisirs
que Dieu vise
à provoquer
dans nos cœurs
au sein de nos familles
pour représenter
cet aspect générosité
de Dieu
selon sa richesse
il pourvoira
avec gloire
donc ici la gloire
elle est en train
de qualifier
pas forcément
la richesse
de Dieu
qui est glorieuse
mais elle est en train
de qualifier
plutôt la manière
dont Dieu pourvoit
donc quelle est
l'intention des policiers
vous contemplez ma vie
vous avez vu des fois
que moi j'étais
complètement exposé
à la mort
j'étais au bord
de mourir
au bord de la persécution
au bord
de la privation totale
mais vous avez vu
comment Dieu
a tiré
de la gloire
par la manière
dont il m'a délivré
vous comprenez
c'est pour dire
ne soyez pas toujours
dans l'anticipation
d'avoir toutes les ressources
pour vous lancer
dans les ministères
pour prendre des risques
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est sachez
que même si vous avancez
et que vous ne voyez pas
encore comment les choses
vont se régler
avancez
si vous êtes sûr
que c'est la direction
de Dieu pour vous
car Dieu
a cette capacité
de nous dire
à chaque jour
souffre sa peine
les lendemains
porteront ses soins
je ne peux pas souffrir
aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il me manque
encore 15 jours
avant la fin du mois
car
à chaque jour
souffre sa peine
et les démons
porteront ses soins
c'est notre Père Céleste
le Père de la provision
quotidienne
qui a
une sagesse
infinie
en gloire
pour tirer sa gloire
par la manière
dont il pourvoira
toujours
à l'avancement
de son église
et ensuite
l'apôtre Paul
il va dire
à notre Dieu
et Père
soit la gloire
au siècle
des siècles
Amen
donc c'est impossible
pour l'apôtre Paul
d'évoquer
un Dieu
si glorieux
si généreux
une promesse
si réconfortante
qui repose
sur son église
sans que la vérité
saisie par la raison
soit accompagnée
d'adoration
d'affection
des joies
donc la racine
du mot
doxologie
cette adoration
a pour racine
la gloire
de Dieu
et quelle est la gloire
de ces dieux
c'est la gloire
d'un Dieu
qui est notre Dieu
qui est mon Dieu
qui est Père
c'est le privilège
que les chrétiens ont
d'avoir Dieu
pour Père
le nom
que nous avons
pour Dieu
est Père
c'est un Père
avec un amour
très intéressé
pour les bien-être
de ses enfants
pour les mieux
c'est un Père
qui a pourvu
les plus importants
dont on avait besoin
c'est lui
qui a vécu
la vie parfaite
à notre place
qui est mort
à la croix
pour nous
et qui par la foi
en lui
nous sommes adoptés
par Dieu
les Pères
et nous recevons
de la part des Jeux
les mêmes traitements
que les fils méritent
laissez voir
il a fait de nous
des héritiers
avec Christ
de toutes les choses
de l'univers
créés
et glorifiés
cette semaine
on a eu
un moment tendu
à la maison
car un de nos enfants
n'a pas appelé
maman de maman
elle l'a appelée
par son nom
et c'est vrai
que ça doit être
l'une des choses
les plus sustantes
et c'est même
dangereux parfois
où des fois
on veut
trop équilibrer
les choses
les respects
etc
c'est important
le Christ lui-même
a toujours dit
Père Saint
Père Juste
mais il a toujours
dit Père
nous n'avons pas
ces privilèges
avec nos patrons
nous n'avons pas
ces privilèges
avec les présidents
et soyez sûrs
que les présidents
et les patrons
préfèrent
qu'ils leur
enfant
l'appelle
Père
que patron
ou président
c'est une offense
pour Dieu
les dieux
Père
qui non seulement
dans la manière
dont on évoque
son nom
on ne l'appelle
pas Père
surtout une fois
adoptée par Christ
surtout devant
l'unfa
du Nouveau Testament
mais ça ne sert
!
pas à grande chose
de l'appeler Père
et mener
une attitude
envers la vie
marquée par l'anxiété
par exemple
marquée par
l'anticipation
du Père
marquée
par les doutes
quant à l'avenir
et pourquoi
c'est une offense
envers Dieu
car toute
l'emphase
biblique
nous conduit
au privilège
de savoir
que nous pouvons
non seulement
considérer
mais réjouir
de cette intimité
divine
comme l'intimité
d'un enfant
avec son Père
d'être sûr
qui est le Dieu
créateur
de l'univers
le Dieu
à qui
tous les atomes
disent Amen
le Dieu
à qui
toutes les planètes
disent Amen
qui nous a assurés
que nous sommes
la prunelle
de ses yeux
nous sommes
son troupeau
son église
nous sommes
ses enfants
et les cheveux
de notre tête
sont comptés
et qu'il est en train
de gouverner
chaque seconde
de nos vies
pour former
son caractère
en nous
pour faire promouvoir
son évangile
à travers nous
pour nous sanctifier
et pour nous donner
des fraîches
et de nouvelles manifestations
de sa présence
dans nos vies
donc c'est impossible
de dire
mon Dieu
pour voir
tout besoin
selon sa richesse
avec gloire
en Jésus Christ
et de ne pas dire
ensuite
tout de suite
comme Paul faisait
très souvent
en sortant
complètement
de tout cadre
formel
des lettres
en coupant
son raisonnement
avec de l'adoration
explosion d'adoration
d'entendre
en amène
ou en gloire
à Dieu
lorsqu'on est en train
de méditer
dans ce type
de passage
en cherchant
à réagir
de manière extrême
au mouvement
carimatique
très sentimentaliste
parfois
nous négligeons
les bruits
de la maternité
pour embrasser
les silences
du cimetière
mais Paul
n'était pas gêné
si
lorsqu'il
déclarait
une telle promesse
un autre Dieu
perçoit la gloire
au siècle
des siècles
c'est-à-dire
en Dieu
donc la gloire
est tellement élevée
qu'il est capable
de générer
une adoration
proportionnelle
à la hauteur
de sa gloire
qui produira
des louanges
à travers
tous les siècles
non seulement
les siècles
humains
mais pour
toute l'éternité
dans la gloire
car l'adoration
sera proportionnelle
à la gloire
de Dieu
et nous
en tant qu'êtres
finis
nous serons en train
de glorifier
Dieu
à l'infini
et c'est l'assurance
que l'église
attention
c'est lié à ça
l'église
aura toujours
la provision
de Dieu
pendant toutes
les générations
c'est les seuls
empires
ou royaumes
qui vont prévaloir
contre tous
les autres royaumes
car Dieu
sera en train
de pourvoir
à la croissance
de son église
sera en train
de pourvoir
à ses ministres
aux implantateurs
d'église
aux missionnaires
pour tous les siècles
il sera adoré
mais lorsqu'il
dit
à notre Dieu
et Père
les dieux
de l'univers
et notre Père
à lui soit la gloire
au siècle des siècles
!
et tout de suite
gloire à Dieu!
vous pouvez lire la Bible
par vous-même
Amen!
avec exclamation
au Brésil
quand on est devant
la beauté
dans tel texte
même dans certains cercles
réformés
on dit aux personnes
bouche des béton
on dit Amen!
c'est tout simplement
glorieux
bon
nous devons nous arrêter ici
avec la joie
et l'assurance
et la provision
divine
et mon Dieu
pourvoira
à tous vos besoins
selon sa richesse
avec gloire
en Christ
à notre Dieu
et Père
à la gloire
au siècle des siècles
Amen!